hey youtubers it's Charlie so there's a
prologue to Doctor Who series 9 so this
is gonna be a breakdown of what that is
if you were confused it might seem like
a trailer because it's only like a
minute and a half two minutes long but
it really is the full prologue it just
meant to set the stage for why the
doctor is on the run he's putting off
going to see a certain person like they
say he's been seeking your presence his
servants are searching for you
everywhere now obviously that sounds
like the master it might also be this
person from the trailer that looks like
he's dressed the same way as The
Sisterhood of Karn
and if that wasn't clear that's where he
is he's with The Sisterhood of Karn it's
the same actress from the 50th
anniversary from the night of the doctor
that was another very infamous prologue
that brought back Paul McGann the 8th
doctor every everyone freaked out
whenever he showed up the 50th
anniversary episode itself was pretty
amazing but that was probably one of my
favorite things about the whole
experience
just the fact that Moffat brought him
back if you don't know who the
Sisterhood of Karn is or you didn't see
that little mini episode the night of
the doctor there is sisterhood that
lives on the planet Karn that's
dedicated to preserving the sacred flame
that's just a mystical heat source that
produces the elixir of life and that's
actually the big thing that was what the
8th doctor drank to help influence his
regeneration David Tennant made the joke
during the 50th anniversary that
regeneration is a lottery he was mostly
making fun of the Matt Smith doctor but
Time Lords can actually influence their
regeneration like if they know something
specific that they want to regenerate
into Paul McGann's doctor knew that the
time war was coming and wanted to
regenerate into a warrior doctor
so the elixir of life just aided in that
transition in the context of this Peter
Capaldi episode this little mini episode
they're more like a proxy for the Time
Lords
now remember Karn not the same planet as
Gallifrey it's it's a completely
different place
so when Gallifrey was put into the
pocket universe Karn was not so when we
see him here he's not inside the pocket
universe he's still in normal space I'm
thinking of them is like the low-rent
post office for Gallifrey and until
Gallifrey actually comes back they have
a nice back-and-forth about the doctor
lying and then he you know he runs off
after giving her something now this is
the confession dial the last will and
testament of a Time Lord when he says
you know who to give this to obviously
talking about the master because Missy
has it when we see Clara in the trailer
for the first episode you guys can let
me know though you know based on their
conversation do you think that the
person
that he is putting off meeting is the
master most of that conversation does
reference his relationship with the
master you've known him your whole life
and you've been enemies for most of it
an enemy is just someone that you don't
know yet
so this whole prologue could be an
extended conversation about him putting
off a meeting with the master or they
could be talking about two different
people you guys let me know which you
think it is mostly I think it's just the
master but but don't forget this
character from the trailer the
sinister-looking character also shows up
in the first episode and if it wasn't
cleared the first two episodes are a
two-parter technically I mean I mean
they're like two different episodes that
will air on different nights but it's
one story stretched over two episodes
congratulations to this week's giveaway
winner Nathan HU and a $20 Amazon gift
card just messaged me on the back end of
my channel so and get your contact info
for those who don't know I'm doing a
weekly Doctor Who giveaway for series 9
so each time a new episode posts are
like you know each new week I'll be
doing a new round of the giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be subscriber
and leave a comment on this video now
because the first episode is coming next
Saturday what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
do a Q&A like I would normally do but
once all the TV comes back because
Doctor Who is airing during the fall
when a bunch of other shows are on I
don't know if I'll be able to do a Q&A
each week but I'll still do a giveaway
so so we'll figure it out no worries
series 9 is gonna be a ton of fun we got
Maisie Williams and I think the master
is gonna be a little more complex like
won't just be your standard villain for
the entire season right now though you
can click here to learn all about River
Song coming back that's just for the
Christmas special completely different
story and you can click here for the
last big trailer with Maisie Williams
thank you so much watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight